Oxford
University is well known for being one of
the most prestigious and elite places of learning
in history.
Over the years, it has seen some of the finest
minds the world has ever known pass through
its halls.
It’s also the place where over six centuries
ago a bunch of students and a fair number
of townsfolk were killed in a riot over a
pint.
While many details about what has come to
be known as “The St Scholastica’s Day
Riots” have been lost, and others are occasionally
conflicting given the documentation of the
day (which is perhaps not surprising when
reading accounts from two groups that detest
one another), we do know more or less how
events transpired.
For starters, in every reputable account,
the riots began on the 10th of February 1355,
which just so happens to be known as “St
Scholastica’s Day”- a day of feasting
meant to honor St Scholastica, the sister
of the perhaps more well known St Benedict.
On that day, a number of Oxford students were
drinking at an establishment called the Swindlestock
tavern (a.k.a. Swyndlestock Tavern) when two
of the students began complaining about the
quality of the ale on offer.
Exactly who these students were isn’t known
for certain, but they are commonly claimed
to have been named Walter Spryngeheuse and
Roger de Chesterfield.
Whether that was really their names or not,
the students were extremely dissatisfied with
the quality of the alcoholic beverages they’d
been served and complained to the landlord,
supposedly named John de Croyden, directly.
Allegedly, the landlord responded to these
complaints with “stubborn and saucie language”
which, if you’ve ever been in a pub, is
probably how approximately 99% of all landlords
would react to being rudely told their drinks
taste a bit like pigswill.
The students, not liking the landlord’s
attitude, decided that they’d express their
displeasure by hurling their tankards directly
in his face.
What happened immediately after isn’t clear.
But eventually, the infuriated landlord roused
the local populace by ringing the town church’s
bell which in turn caused the students to
do the same with the bell located in the university’s
church, with both sides rallying.
Soon after, a riot erupted between the two
groups when arrests against the two initial
instigators were attempted.
The riots quickly grew out of hand including
an estimated two thousand additional townsfolk
joining the fray after rumours of the riot
and the sound of ringing bells reached the
countryside.
Bouts of violence involving bows, arrows,
swords, axes and, of course, fists continued
well into the night and the next day.
Ultimately, the townsfolk managed to storm
the university grounds and kill 63 students,
as well as injuring many more.
The students, in turn, reportedly managed
to kill upwards of 30 or so townsfolk during
the melee.
At first glance, this may seem a little over
the top for what seems to have started as
a fairly minor altercation between a handful
of people in a pub.
But the thing to keep in mind is that at this
point in history, the university and its students
held a ludicrous amount of power over the
town, to the point where the students were
in many ways above the law.
As noted in the book, Student Resistance:
A History of the Unruly Subject: “At the
turn of the 13th century thousands of students
roamed the streets randomly attacking hapless
citizens and sheriffs who couldn’t touch
the marauding students out of fear of state
retaliation.”
In fact, only a little over a century before,
another riot between the Oxford students and
the townsfolk had started after students murdered
a townswoman.
Some of the students fleeing the ensuing riot
ultimately helped found the University of
Cambridge, today the second oldest university
in England after Oxford.
Beyond more or less being above the law, the
students were also exempt from being able
to be sued in court outside of their diocese,
as well as exempt from paying certain taxes.
Needless to say, from the beginning up until
somewhat recently in history, significant
clashes between Oxford students and the surrounding
townsfolk were relatively frequent.
The university and its students were able
to get away with all this because, at that
point in history, Oxford was essentially another
arm of the Church, meaning its power was pretty
much absolute.
This was no better proved than when King Edward
III caught wind of the riot and instead of
trying to get to the bottom of what happened,
he decided instead to impose harsh penalties
on the entire town and arrest any citizen
he felt had something to do with the riots.
These penalties included, among other things,
forcing the mayor to march with a bare head
to the university to beg forgiveness from
the Vice-Chancellor and then pay a fine of
63 pennies (one for every scholar killed)
on the anniversary of the riots, every year,
for all time.
This was a tradition that was upheld for almost
five centuries, right up until 1825 when “the
mayor simply refused to continue the practice.”
On top of forcing the mayor to beg forgiveness
on behalf of the townsfolk every year for
just under half a millennium, the university
was also initially given control of certain
trade in the town, including the trade of
wine and beer.
So, in the end, by all appearances it would
seem it was the landlord’s fault for not
brewing better alcohol and then having the
audacity to have his face get in the way
of
the thrown drinks by
the
Oxford students.